[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i thought baseball did a great job
at the all-star festivities the all-star
game home run derby
and one of the great story lines our
next guest trey mancini uh
full name is joseph anthony mancini
nicknamed
boom boom by his dad when he was uh
younger
the baltimore orioles first baseman and
he was diagnosed with stage three colon
cancer that was last march started chemo
last april
completed chemo in september came back
major league baseball
in february and finished runner-up at
home run derby with pete alonso
trey good to have you on the program how
you feeling today
doing well thanks for having me on dan
uh give us an idea what the experience
the atmosphere was like for home run
derby
it was incredible it was unlike anything
i've experienced before um you know
whenever you go out on the field and
there's 50
000 plus people there um to watch you
take bp
it's really strange um and and something
i haven't experienced before and
and i haven't been in a stadium that
packed in a very long time so
um there's a big adrenaline rush that
went with it and uh there are some
nerves early on but at the same time i
just
really really enjoyed it because i don't
know what
you know are you worried about missing a
pitch or you know
hitting a dribbler or something there
like what what is that mindset when you
go to the plate
yeah that didn't go through my mind too
much but uh you know the first minute i
got off to a really slow start and i
took a timeout earlier than i
anticipated and i
i was there and i'm like okay you gotta
get it together and at least look
respectable uh these next two minutes
and show that you deserve to be here and
um luckily was able to calm myself down
my teammate cedric came over
and manny machado was there my former
teammate and they gave me a nice little
pep talk
and uh it helped me help me out a lot
calming down and luckily
you know i i had a really good final two
minutes and then got the bonus round too
how curious were you to watch shohei
ohtani
extremely we actually just played them a
week and a half ago out in la
and he hit a couple bombs i think 460
feet plus and um you know he's
incredible he makes it look so easy too
and and there's not really much of a
weakness in his game that i've seen at
all and obviously he's an elite pitcher
as well as an elite hitter
and base runner and um you know
everything and when you stick him in the
outfield he's a lead out there too so
um it's just incredible to watch and
it's it's historic
i maintain that i could listen to him
take batting practice like just there
there's a difference in the ball coming
off his
bat trey there is and i i watched him uh
obviously during the derby but
beforehand we all got
a little bit of time to practice with
our batting practice pictures
and i was watching him hit and i saw him
hit some balls that i i haven't seen
hit that far before so it was incredible
and it was really fun to watch it up in
person i
i felt like a fan watching him um
because
he was the last hitter to go and it was
getting ready
i was getting ready for the second round
but i wanted to stay out and watch him
hit instead of going to
you know get warmed up and take my swing
so i really wanted to watch johay hid
out there
did you feel like an underdog in the
contest
i did a little bit um just because i i
think on a on a national scale a lot
a lot of people might not know exactly
who i am um obviously my story has
been pretty big this year but um still
outs outside of baltimore and and
outside of like you know people that
really follow baseball a lot i think a
lot of people might not have known me in
my story so
um yeah i felt like a little bit of an
underdog and especially
not being in the all-star game and and
um you know but getting invited to be in
the home run derby i wanted to show that
i
belong there instead of being a you know
courtesy invite because of what happened
so
um you know i'm really happy with how it
ended up i know you said you wanted to
use the home run derby to show people
that there's life after a cancer
diagnosis
at what point did you start to embrace
you weren't an oh woe
is me guy from everything i've read it
was basically nope let's go
gotta go gotta attack it here where's
that come from
yeah whenever you get diagnosed you're
in a fight or flight mode um you know
it's it's time to fight and you gotta
get through it and i think
after you finish treatments you're kind
of left wondering like
what just happened to me like you can't
believe it um but whenever you're going
through it it's just
go go go all the time um and it can be
tough especially after it's over but i
wanted to show that you can go on to
live
your normal life afterwards you really
can and you can't let
you know the fear of it ever returning
and what happened to you
um you know over overtake you and you
you have to beat it and go on and live
your life what's the worst
moment that you had with it uh there
were there were quite a few there
there's a lot of good days and then
there
there are some bad days but um you know
it was really tough on me when chadwick
bozeman passed away
he passed away from the same you know
same same cancer that i was fighting at
the time and it was really hard
and um you know after that i took it
really hard i was a big fan of his and
and
loved the movie 42 and and he played
jackie robinson in that
and um you know he he seemed like a
larger and like
larger-than-life figure so um for the
disease to take his life was
really tough on me because you know some
people talk and my father
died of cancer you get the diagnosis
and then you go into this oh wo was me
or sell you know you want
pity and then you know that's where my
mom played a really large role where she
basically giving my dad a pep talk there
did somebody give you that pep talk that
said
hey let's go feel sorry for yourself
today now we got to go after this thing
basically any time i had started to feel
sorry for myself my girlfriend sarah
um you know whipped me back into shape
pretty quick she's absolutely amazing
and so strong throughout the entire
thing
um i i would not have gone through it
without her and she was with me
every day um she took care of me all
last year because it was during the
pandemic my parents were able to
come up a couple times even though the
pandemic was was going on
um so i did get to see them some and
they were you know i talked to them
every day and they were so supportive
from afar but
given the circumstances in the world it
was by and large
sarah and i um most of the time so
um she she was incredible and so strong
and and helped me get through it
so well what was that like your first
appearance after going through all of
this
it was it was surreal it was a spring
training game and
spring trainings basically glorified
practice games so i wasn't really
expecting too many emotions or
adrenaline or anything like that going
into the game but
i got to the field that day and it was
just so strange being back
where i was the year before where i got
diagnosed with colon cancer
and then you know here i am the healthy
again
and and i've been through a lot but i'm
going to be playing in a game again
almost a year to the day that um i had
last appeared in a game so
it was incredible and and i got a
standing ovation from the fans and it
was definitely the most emotional spring
training moment
i don't think i'll have another spring
training moment like that
they don't make movies about spring
training there trey you know
major league i think had a couple scenes
from spring training that's all i can
think of
uh who provided comic relief through all
of this
oh i mean i we we watched a lot of tv
shows sarah and i
um so we we got it through that i mean
i'm a humongous fan of the office i've
watched a show
like i think 50 000 times but you know i
still laugh every day
if we watch that so um you know we watch
things like that
and and um you know i have so many
friends that
um you know would make me laugh and and
and
things like that and sarah also made me
laugh all the time so you you need that
whenever you're going through this
uh are you cancer-free like what's your
diagnosis as far as follow-ups go
yeah so i mean everything looks
fantastic
so far but after you have stage three
colon cancer go through chemotherapy you
go through about a five year
surveillance period
where um for the first year every three
months you get checked up
and then the next year it's every six
months and then it's yearly for the next
three years after that so
um i'm getting checked up again in
september
and then after that it progresses to six
months so you get uh
ct scans and then i have really highly
specific blood tests that i do too and
so far everything looks great i feel
great about everything and
and my future but it's still something
that you have to deal with even after
it's over
what if i got you an autographed picture
from uh kevin from the office
would you uh would you be interested in
getting i actually noticed
his uh mug in front of you i would love
that
yeah i'm a huge fan well plus when he
spills the chili i mean they're
one of the best and that's that's that
was one take he said that he did it one
time that was it
and they had to replace the carpet as he
spilled all the uh the chili
but it's still if i'm ever in a bad mood
and if i'm feeling low you can watch
that and i don't care what you're going
through you can feel a little bit better
single time yeah that would have been
tough if it was more than one take that
would have been uh
pretty tough so i'm happy for him that
it was only one take
uh are you okay with uh baseball
changing the rules no more
seven inning uh double headers here and
uh we're getting rid of the guy on
second base
to start extra innings um you know what
as a player i
i haven't minded the rules too much uh
the seven ending double headers are
uh nice two nine inning games in a day
is a lot but
at the same time um you know that is a
classic baseball game and and
um so so i have no problem with it
changing back but i have not minded the
change in rules either
uh did any pitcher take it easy on you
did anybody
want to just you know give you a
meatball down the down the middle
most definitely not uh yeah they
if they did i i i wouldn't be too happy
with them uh as nice as that sounds
you know i i don't want any sympathy or
uh you know courtesy meatballs from
anybody else and i know
uh the pictures this year i feel like
are almost more than any other year
they're just getting better and better
and they know how to pitch and
um yeah it's tough it's it's tough on a
day-to-day basis going out there and
facing these guys
are you doing a website or anything i
know you want to raise awareness here
i'm curious if you and your girlfriend
or your agent have started something yes
so i have a foundation it's called the
trey mancini foundation
and so my older sister actually is the
one that started it my younger sister
helps out and sarah helps out and my
agent is also involved and
um you know a lot of what we do is to
benefit
colon cancer and raise awareness but we
also do a backpack program in baltimore
to benefit
kids up there so basically anything that
resonates with us we want to get behind
and we do a lot of different fundraisers
for different causes but right now our
main things are colon cancer awareness
and the backpack program
great to talk to you trey and uh i know
you want to be known as a ball player
but you know what if you can raise any
kind of awareness
uh there's nothing wrong with being
known as that ball player who helped
a lot of people and maybe save some
lives absolutely yeah i
really appreciate it dan thanks for
having me on that's uh trey mancini the
oil's first baseman
and uh finished runner-up home run derby
to uh pete alonso